Welcome to A.B. Testing Podcast, your modern testing podcast.
Your hosts, Alan, Spy, and Brent, not here, will be here to guide you through topics on
testing, leadership, agile, and anything else that comes to mind.
Now on with the show.
Hey everyone, welcome back to the A.B. testing podcast.
I am Spy.
I am not joined by Brent again.
Brent has moved on.
He is actually polishing the axles on Satya's Porsche, actually on Satya's fleet of Porsches.
So those are getting all nice and shiny and lubed up and ready for a special Porsche off-roading
adventure that Satya is going on.
In the meantime, we have Valmer back on the show again.
Valmer was on here a few weeks ago and I wanted to go a little bit deeper talking
to him.
So Valmer, say hi and reintroduce yourself to the audience, all three of them.
Hey, Alan.
Thanks for having me again.
It's a pleasure to be here and I hope everyone enjoys the show today.
They will.
You are.
Well, there's only two people left after you, so they will listen.
It will be great.
Happy to have you here.
A couple of things we talked about last time piqued my interest though.
We can go a little bit deeper and I don't know, we can just, I'm going to have
opinions.
I also want to let you talk about some things you want to talk about.
And when we chatted over Slack and over Slack, if you want to be in our Slack group,
you can go to one of the three, actually go to modern testing dot org where you can
get a link to join our Slack group.
It's the activity faded while I was gone on my long hike, but it's it's picking
back up again.
Always looking for folks to join me, talk about things, but we're always happy
to have discussions there as well.
So Valmer, I'm going to turn it over to you.
I'd like you to talk about, as we discussed, some of the things you've been doing in
the role of not just a QA engineer, but a QA advisor, an educator.
And I'm going to jump in a little bit, but I'm just going to leave it open for
you. Let's talk about what you've been up to and why it may be interesting to
our audience.
Of course. And first of all, I highly recommend anyone listening to the
podcast to join the Slack group.
Great conversations there.
Nice discussions as well.
So I think I'm going to start with a little bit of background of who I am.
I am a Brazilian who has been living here in Europe for around 10 years, and
I've been working with quality assurance for the past 21 years.
I started my career doing manual testing and got bored to doing the same
thing that I did yesterday, today, knowing that I would be doing the same
things tomorrow as well.
So I decided to learn programming, which I didn't like in the beginning.
And this is why I started my career in software development as a software
tester, a manual tester.
But after I started learning programming to automate the work that I was
doing, I kind of got passionate about software development in general.
Of course, started with test automation of the work that I was doing
manually, but kind of got interested in the whole software development
lifecycle, learned a little bit of front-end, a little bit of back-end, a
little bit of continuous integration, infrastructure, all that is related to
software development.
For the past at least 10 or 11 years, I've been working more focused
on test automation, moved from a role where I was the person that was
responsible for writing the tests, and nowadays very aligned with what you
and Brent and your guests discuss here and in the Slack group as well.
I'm more into disseminating the quality culture to everyone involved in
developing software because I think quality is everyone's responsibility.
At the company I work nowadays, I am still the person kind of responsible
for some kind of test automation while we are maturing in this matter, but
always with the mindset of disseminating knowledge so everyone can
contribute to that kind of stuff.
As an educator, I kind of started sharing knowledge in 2014 with a blog.
Afterwards, in 2015, I started a YouTube channel.
Actually, the A-B testing podcast inspired me to have my own podcast as
well.
After a while, for a moment, I was hosting three different podcasts, two of
them in Portuguese, one of them in English.
The one in Portuguese is the translation would be something like testing
abroad, where we invite guests that work with software testing but live
abroad to bring this experience for our audience.
The other one is called Tech and Accent.
It's kind of to this mystify that you have to have a perfect accent to live
and work abroad if you are a native speaker.
And the other one is the one of my brand talking about testing, where I
invite guests to talk about software development in general.
And after I was doing podcasts, YouTube and blog, I also started an
online course teaching test automation.
At the moment, I have more than 24,000 students that I have already
teached with online recorded courses.
Geez.
That's a little bit about myself.
You have more reach than the three listeners of the A-B testing
podcast.
What are you doing here, slumming over here?
Yeah, but that's a little bit about myself.
I am passionate about sharing knowledge.
It's the way I learn the most.
In the beginning, when I started my blog, I was the first consumer of it.
And I learn a lot by sharing the knowledge that I gain.
Because I think if I can pass to others what I am learning and they
understand, it means that I am understanding better what I am learning.
It's one of the reasons the old angerweasel.com blog, I did that
partially because I learned things myself by trying to write about
them, but also trying to just share some of the education.
And if you remember, the reason the A-B testing podcast is around
is one, just because Brent and I wanted a place to hang out.
But two, we wanted to talk about the changes that were happening.
You've lived some of these and give people an idea of what those
may look like.
It's around, I don't think all of what we do education, but awareness, at least.
So I have a couple of questions.
One is, before I forget, after we're done here, please send me as many links
as you want for me to put in the show notes, and I'll include those
when I post this.
But you've been in the business for a while, done a lot of things, the
traditional test things, also moving into let's help the team ship better
quality.
Can you talk a little bit more of what that shift's been like, especially
like, because a lot of people will dig their heads in the sand and not
believe this change is happening.
What was that change like for you in the company?
Did they accept it?
Did they push back?
Was it natural?
Was it mandated?
I'm kind of curious what that transition was like, both for you
personally and for the company.
Yeah.
So when I started my career, I worked in very big and enterprise
companies.
So I worked for HP, I worked for Dell computers.
I worked for automatic data processing, which are American companies
that have their offices in Brazil as well.
And the first time I moved to a more, let's say, agile way of
working was when I moved from my hometown, Porto Alegre in the
south of Brazil to a startup in Florianópolis, also in the south of
Brazil, one of the most beautiful cities in Brazil, if I can say.
And in this company, we were around 20 people, around 12 developers.
And it's kind of funny because I was hired as the second tester of
this company because the other tester that they have there was
working for two years and he couldn't take vacation because he was the
only one that knew how to write the automated tests.
And so he trained me.
And that's, I'm going to interrupt for a second.
That's a problem into itself, right?
If you're ever in a position where you can't take a vacation,
something over overarching is wrong.
Anyway, please continue.
Yeah.
So he trained me so he could take vacation afterwards.
He went on vacation.
He came back and I thought to myself, what if this guy lives,
we might be able to go on vacations as well.
So I decided to change the approach to not be the only one doing testing.
So one of the approaches that I used, so we were doing test
automation using Cucumber in a programming language that was not
the language that the developers were used to write code.
And at that time, there was a new test framework coming up.
We were starting a project using the same technology.
And then I decided, what if we move for this specific project to this
other framework that is in the same language that the developers are already
used to, and then we started experimenting with it and we start.
And I started doing knowledge sharing sessions, pair programming, pair
testing with the developers, coding dojos.
So I could go on vacation and they could take care of the
tasks when I was not there.
I would say it was a success.
I worked for this company for a couple of years before I moved
from Brazil to Europe and they never hired a QA anymore.
And they still build very high quality software.
When was this?
What year was this?
It was from 2014 until 2016.
Which is great because what's interesting is that is right around
the time the A-B testing podcast first started, but that is
principle number seven in action.
You spread information across the team so you don't need
specialists to bottleneck the system.
So that's incredible.
And so I'll just point out again, this is the echo chamber of our
audience who all get this, but there is a large group of engineering
teams out there who just don't believe that can happen, but, or
think I'm making stuff up that I'm being somehow aspirational, but
these things are happening before Brent and I even began talking
about them, which comes back to the reason we talked about it.
Cause we saw it happening.
It's happening more.
It's just very interesting.
Anyway, please continue.
Yeah.
And after that, I moved to Europe first.
I moved to Norway.
I worked in a company that do video conferences, video
conferencing service that runs in the web.
It was kind of one of the first video conferences services that was using
WebRTC, which is an open source project by Google that run that you
can do like web socket connection to the peer to peer video and audio
connection, which was a very interesting challenge because usually
when you were doing test automation, you were testing things with you
think about the end user perspective.
You open a browser and you interact with the application as the
user, just with one browser in this company, we were opening lots of
browsers, Chrome in one side, Firefox in another side, and checking
if video and audio was being transmitted from one side to the
other, if screen sharing was working.
And in this company, I was hired because I had specialized in this
framework that we used in the other company that they decided to
experiment with and they were building their software using
Angular and I was like kind of starting to get to become an
expert in Protractor, which was the test mission to that.
I remember Protractor.
Wow.
I even wrote a book about it, which discontinuated the framework,
but it was quite an experience.
As a quick aside, that's funny because when I worked on Microsoft
Teams, which is worse now, again, I was working on it about that
time, 2016, we made the design choice, should we use React,
should we use Angular, and we decided on Angular, wrong
choice, oh well, so we used a lot of Protractor was the way to
write automation for that, but the devs wrote it, but anyway,
interesting flash from the past, please continue.
Yeah, and it's interesting because so I moved me and my
wife and a couple of cats we brought from Brazil to Europe
and I was working super happy.
I was a user of the service I was building even before
joining the company, but my wife, she works with marketing.
It was impossible for her to get a job in the Nordics without
speaking a Nordic language, so we decided we had to move to
a more international place.
And then we went from Norway to Amsterdam to live in the Netherlands
where we spend four years in there, passed by many different companies
because I think I mentioned to you in the last episode that I am very
selective with the kind of work that I get.
And if I am not happy, I don't mind just leaving.
So I jumped from one job to another until I found something
that was interested to me.
You wanted to say something?
Yeah, I mean, that was the thing right before we recorded.
I said there was something I wanted to dive into.
So if I can have a tangent for a moment.
Of course.
I wanted to, that story you told last time where you got a job
and you showed up on the first day and said, nah, and you left that job.
So one, I love that story.
And two, as I've mentioned, I am looking for a job.
I'm being selective.
I'm thinking about what I want to do.
And I've actually gone back and forth a little bit on,
do I want to work for a company?
Do I want to maybe I'll try and do some consulting.
I think that I think if I did the consulting thing, I think it would snow.
I think it was snowball.
But also, I don't know if I I may want to I may want to work in a company first
and first of the year interest is spiking up.
So there are some more opportunities out there.
I'm figuring out what I want to do.
But I am after my last gig, I am so afraid of showing up to a job that I am
where all the interviews go great.
They tell me all the things I want to hear.
I feel like, yeah, this is it.
I feel good about day one.
And I get there and I go, oh, no.
So I hope I hope I can one
a couple of things I want to ask you
that aren't all about me, but they are all about me.
It's my podcast, dammit.
I I I would love to have that courage to leave.
And I think I'm kind of setting myself up.
I have a job that requires, you know, I'm an air quote relocation.
I made I would not move.
I would get temporary housing and try it out for a walk.
So I'm not going to sell myself to that.
And also, I would negotiate for more remote work.
But I'm curious.
So that's that's I'm going to do a lot of due diligence.
Now, I'm going to track down employees that work at these
whatever company I decided to go to and really figure out what it's like
before I go there.
I want to make sure I can do what I do and do what I do best
safely and in a good environment where I can actually have the impact
I want to have. If that fails, I want to be not afraid to say,
you know what? Nope.
I'm going to try again and, you know, take whatever comes back with that.
So the question I have is I want to know more about like what we're
one, what were the things that really what was the tipping point
that really made you say no, really noped you out of there.
And then two, if you could do it again and like there are some due
diligence, like during the interview or during the lead up to taking that job.
What would you do differently now?
Well, actually, it was a little bit of my fault as well.
So the main thing is that I've been working remotely
since before the pandemic.
So when I was still living in the Netherlands, I worked for GitLab,
which started as a remote company.
I joined them when they were already like a big company for a pre IPO.
And I got used to working remotely and I continued working remotely
all other gigs that I worked for.
And in the Netherlands, there was a time that I decided to quit my job
when I was at GitLab for a year and a half to work on my own my own business.
I am a kind of an entrepreneur, have a company with just myself.
When you were saying that I might work for myself, I might work
for someone else, for a company.
I do both nowadays.
I have my own company, I have my own clients and I have
my own job as well, like as an employee.
So I quit my job at GitLab, spent like a kind of a sabbatical year
thinking about life while building my own business and trying things
and failing and adjusting.
I want to live here.
I like the way you're living your life.
I just want to say that.
Traveling, living abroad, taking a year off to think about
what you want to do, having a balance between your own stuff
and the corporate stuff.
I like it.
And I would say that it's like a partnership between me and my wife.
She was dependent of my visa for a while.
I had to be dependent of her visa for a while as well.
We are Brazilians.
We live in Europe.
We don't have a European citizenship.
So we depend on a working visa to stay in Europe still.
Nowadays, we have applied for Spanish citizenship, which is
probably going to come this year, but we still depend on a visa.
So this is really a partnership between the both of us.
So I decided that I want to have a sabbatical to work on my own stuff
and think about what I was going to do afterwards.
Worked for a company in the Netherlands before moving to Spain
for about five months.
And then I decided to leave because we wanted to move again.
So we lived in Oslo, in Norway, then in the Netherlands, in Amsterdam.
And there were three things that we did not like.
One, the weather.
We are Brazilians.
We have very good weather in Brazil.
We got not used to the weather, nor in Oslo,
neither in Amsterdam.
The language is a great barrier for you to feel part of the country you live.
I speak a little bit of Norwegian, but I can't communicate.
I can't have a conversation with someone that speaks fluently
in Norwegian.
I can just read some things and introduce myself,
but I can't make a conversation.
I never learned Norwegian Dutch.
It's a very difficult language.
So we decided that we wanted to move to a place
that we would have a good weather,
culture that is more similar to us,
and also a language that we speak.
So we came to Spain where we have the three things.
My wife, we speak Spanish.
We have a Latin culture.
We are Latins.
And we have a very good weather here in Barcelona where we live.
And in Barcelona, I started working for Typeform at first.
I worked for them with them for almost a year.
And my role at Typeform was quality assistance,
assistant.
So we had a team of four quality assistants,
and we were basically assisting many developer teams
that have different needs in terms of quality.
Some of them need a hand with test automation.
Some of them were doing test automation just great,
and we would give them a hand with, I don't know.
There was a case where we were using
a very expensive SAS for doing visual regression testing.
So we decided to experiment with open source solutions
that we could host on our own
and replace the very expensive one.
So we did that.
We were doing trainings and that kind of thing.
And then there were layoffs.
The quality team was dismantled.
And I decided, you know what?
I'm going to go back to what I did in the Netherlands,
focus on my own job, on my own business.
And I did that for about two years.
In these two years that I, like when you do,
like most of my clients, they are from Brazil,
and I live in Europe.
And the Brazilian currency is very low
if you make the change between Brazilian reais and euros.
So you have to get quite a big amount of money
to have clients in Brazil to live in Europe.
So I was experimenting with different things,
like my online courses were giving me
some part of my revenue.
At the same time, I was experimenting
with different kind of services that I could offer,
doing a little bit of consulting for a few clients.
So one thing that I did, which I did already five classes,
was a mentorship called Test Design Masterclass
where I teach software design applied to test automation,
to software testing.
This masterclass, I teach more than 40 students
on this already, and it was inspired by this book here
that I'm going to show you.
It's called A Philosophy of Software Design.
I have not read that one.
And I love the cover, which is kind of spaghetti coat on top.
Then you apply the philosophy of software design,
and then you have very well decoupled software in the bottom.
I'd like to point out for our listeners
that there are very few books on software I haven't read.
There probably are a lot, but I haven't read that one.
It sounds like it's a good one.
I'll put it on my list.
I highly recommend it.
It's from John Osterhout.
He was a professor at the CES course in Stanford.
And he basically wrote the book as what he was doing
at Stanford, the university.
So he was teaching software design
in a very different way that other universities were doing.
So he would give to his students a kind of a softer product
that they had to build.
And they would build it for...
So they would have classes on software design,
but they would have this exercise
of building an application on their own.
And they would send to him for review,
and he would give feedback so they could apply
the principles of software design while they were learning.
And they would have a few rounds of building
and receiving feedback and updating the code
based on the feedback.
And in the second round, they would not send
just for the professor to review,
but also to the other peers.
So I decided to copy what he was doing
teaching software design, but applied to software testing.
So I built a web application,
and I gave to my students the exercise
of you have to write tests for this application.
You have to write end-to-end tests.
You have to write tests for the API.
You have to write tests for the specific components
of the front end.
You have to write accessibility tests
for the things to make sure the application is accessible.
And depending on the level of seniority of the students,
they would have more difficult or easier exercises.
If they were very senior,
they could even apply that
to doing continuous integration as well.
It's been a very nice experiment now.
I'm going to go with the sixth class in June this year.
But after two years just working on my own
for the first year, it worked pretty well.
The second year, it wasn't doing as well as I imagined.
And then I decided to go back to the market.
And then I was very selective on finding a new job.
I got this one that I mentioned.
And now I realize that I am telling all that
because of the question you asked about the job.
Yeah, but before you go on, as we do,
I have two follow-up questions before we get to the end point.
I love the journey here because, again,
it underscores that the principles
that Brendan and I have talked about are not things...
It's not like we invented them and said,
these are going to happen.
We just put some labels on things
that were already happening.
It's great to hear this happen independently.
Two questions.
One's sort of an easy one.
You mentioned at a company you had four quality assistants
and their term quality assistant
I think originally came from Atlassian.
I don't know the name exactly.
They wanted people to help.
They wanted quality folks to help developers
do better testing.
So I understand your journey.
I'm just curious, the other folks
that were quality assistants or quality advisors,
quality coaches, whatever you want to call them,
was that a role they also grew in independently?
Did they have to kind of be taught to do that?
Did they go there because they saw the light of it?
Were they reluctant to do that?
And I ask for a reason,
but I'm just curious to have to describe
every single one of them.
But briefly, what was their journey to this role
and how did they receive it?
Actually, the company didn't have this role before.
They were like normal quality engineers in the beginning.
So they were transitioning to quality assistants
and they hired me when they were in this transition.
So besides helping the developers,
I was also helping my other peers as quality assistants
to grow into this kind of model of working.
How did that go?
It went pretty well, I would say,
especially for the youngest one,
which was not as senior as the other two,
because he was more open-minded.
The other one, they had already their issues.
I'm not surprised.
I think the folks that have been in traditional
versus modern, traditional testing for a long time,
they want to hold onto those roots a little tighter
and moving to giving someone else that expertise
can be difficult for them.
They want to hold on to the notion
that they have the right mindset to do it properly
and nobody else does, which often not all,
a lot of folks will have.
I have a funny story about Microsoft.
Really quickly, when I first worked there,
I worked on networking on Windows 95
and we had a guy there who was a network,
a network admin.
I did a lot of work to make network work.
He was asked to share some of his knowledge with us
so we could all do better network testing
and he refused because he said,
I took certification in classes.
I shouldn't have to share this information,
which is a horrible, horrible approach.
And he was escrowed out of the building the next day.
It was fine, but information sharing is great.
So as people move into these roles,
I worry a little bit that,
I mean, there is a tough transition.
You have to have some sort of leadership support.
The company wanted to move that direction.
So it makes sense.
The other question, and I'm always curious.
But if I can interrupt,
I would say that the other two,
they were not reluctant completely,
but simply the youngest one was more open-minded.
The other one, we complement each other very well.
So there were things that they didn't like to do
and they would do while there were things
that they were very great on doing.
Like teaching disseminating knowledge.
So we would complement each other very well.
I would say.
That's fair.
Thanks for the clarification on that.
That makes sense.
The other question I have, unrelated.
I talked about your test design masterclass.
There's whole books on test design
that are mostly useless.
The trick with test design,
I just talked to some folks
at a company I'm working with
about test design yesterday.
And the challenge is,
if you have, for example, Chad GPT,
here's an application, Chad GPT,
please generate me a list of test cases.
It will generate you a list of test cases
as requested and they'll be fine.
And they'll probably be the test cases
that most testers would generate.
And that's great.
Well, it isn't great because
the trick is in test design
to design not just the tests well,
but design the right tests.
And so much of testing,
whether it's developer testing
or by dedicated testing,
will over test some parts of the application
and under test some other parts
of the application.
That's where principle five,
we use data to help figure out
where the worst in those places may be.
But I'm just curious in your approach
to test design, maybe just give us
a little high level abstract or synopsis.
What is your approach to test design?
And is it does it coincide with the norms
a little off the tracks?
Is there a new approach?
I'm just kind of curious
because this is a even today
where we have developers doing
most of the testing in many teams.
Test design is still a challenge.
So I'm just curious if you can just
just this is a nice little promo
for your course as well.
At a high level,
what is your approach to that?
So what I try to do is pass away
everything that I learned from the moment
that I started working as a tester
until the current moment.
So I kind of invented 14 principles
of test design.
I can list them to you if you don't mind.
The first one is the description
of the suite, the sub suite
and the test cases,
which is more about what you just said,
thinking about what test cases
make sense for the thing you were testing.
Then I talk about test levels,
like the unit testing,
the tests in the top of the pyramid,
the integration testing,
that kind of things.
I talk about abstractions.
I talk about assertions.
I talk about independence,
how tests should be independent
of each other.
I talk about infrastructure
and environments for running
the tests against.
I talk about tools, accessibility,
testability, security,
the size of your tests,
the conventions you should follow,
the arrange, act, assert pattern.
And I talk also about
performance optimizations.
So I give them kind of lecture
about these different topics.
In the beginning,
in the first two classes,
I would give them in the first hour.
So it's like one month classes
on the Saturdays where I would,
in the first hour,
give them lectures.
And in the second time,
it would focus more on the exercises.
And then they would,
after the class,
have to do the exercises on their own.
They would have like four or five days
to do the work and send for my review.
So I would review and they would have,
they would come back with the feedback.
After, in the third one,
I decided that I spend too much time
lecturing about test design.
So I prerecorded the lessons
and I would give them a free course
teaching exactly what I would.
So we would spend more time on practical stuff.
And actually, as an aside,
there's a whole,
in the U.S. where education is poor
to start off with,
there are some folks trying
to make it better.
And one of the techniques they use
is to give students the lecture
to take home
and then use the in-person time
with the instructor
to actually get practical advice
and to walk through stuff
and answer questions.
I think it's very effective.
And it was a learning for me.
It was like something that I realized
that we could spend more time
like with asking questions
and answering them
while they would have
the live time with me.
And then they could take
the lectures on their own.
So the way it works,
it's like through code reviews.
So they have to create,
so they have to fork the project
on GitHub, work on,
clone their own fork
on their own machines,
do the exercises,
create pull requests
so it could review.
And then I would give them
very constructive feedback.
And the feedback
that I would give them
is it would be always related
to one of these 14 principles
that I just mentioned.
And I would tell why they are
not following the principle,
what was the problem
of not following the principle
and how they could apply
the principle
so they would really learn
and they would be able
to apply the principle
in a second round.
And in the last,
in the final class,
I show them my solution.
This is how I would solve.
This is how I would do
all the exercise.
And then we spend
a couple of hours
where I show them
all the test cases
that I wrote
in the different levels
and I explained
the different things
and they can use that
as a reference.
And so that's a little bit
about the test design
master class.
No, that's natural.
I recommend it.
Please send a link
with the other links
you're going to send me.
Of course.
All right.
So here we are.
We are a half hour-ish in,
a little more.
And now lots of background,
which is great.
And lots of interjections
for me, not so great.
But what was the question
I asked?
You'll remember better than I can.
Go ahead and answer it.
It was related to me
leaving the job
in the first day.
Yes, yes.
So after a while,
I decided, you know what?
I want to go back
to work as an employee.
But still having my own company
and I started looking for jobs.
And one of the things that
I thought I was ready
to go back to the office.
So I was looking for,
so as I said,
I am very selective.
So I was looking for
the work that it would be
in a domain that I wanted to work on
with the technology
that I feel comfortable.
But not just because
I feel comfortable,
but because I know
I would be able
to contribute a lot.
But I thought I would be ready
to go back to the office.
And then when I arrived there
in the first day,
I realized that I wasn't.
It was like a very small office
with like,
I don't know,
10 or 20 guys
all in the same small office
in a cool working place
here in Barcelona.
So this is one of the things
that I felt that
I was actually not ready
to go back to the office.
At least not every day.
I wouldn't mind going
once a week or twice maybe.
But having to be there every day,
it was kind of something
that I thought I would be ready,
but I wasn't.
And the other thing is that,
and this is something
that was actually something
that I even mentioned
during the interview process.
And they said that it wouldn't happen,
but it actually happened
is that half of the team
they were Germans and Austrians.
And they would be speaking German
during the work time.
And I felt completely lost.
And I wanted to be
in a more diverse place
where I would have
people from different backgrounds.
But we would always
speak in the same language.
So I would feel part.
So I came to Barcelona
to be in a place
where I understand what people say.
And then I would get a job
where I wasn't understanding
what my colleagues were saying.
So this was the second thing
that made me leave.
And then I decided,
and then I continued
searching for jobs.
And now I'm working
as a senior QA engineer
in a company here in Barcelona.
My role is senior QA engineer
slash QA advisor.
I like that second half.
Talk to me about that.
Do you do more of the first
or more of the second?
So this is how it works.
I work in a company
where we develop different products,
be them mobile products
or web products,
different teams they have there.
It's like as if each product
was like a mini startup.
They have their own stack.
They have their own way of working.
And in the team that I work,
the idea is that we are going to,
we are doing things
differently than most of the teams.
I am a really believer
that if you want a different results,
you have to do things different.
And my manager is very aligned
with that as well.
So we are doing things different
to prove that we can build software
with a very high quality
and that our users
will love the software
that they pay for.
So we can spread it
to the rest of the company.
So I am in this company
in my fourth month
and I'm still working just
as the senior QA engineer
for the team I work on
until we prove
that we are getting
the results that we want.
So we are going to spread
to the rest of the team
and then I'm going to act more
as the advisor
for the rest of the company.
We are actually getting started
with this with some knowledge
sharing sessions about the things
that we are doing differently
and the results that we are getting
from doing these things differently.
And when I say doing things differently
is about using like for example
most of the projects
they use a test framework
that was built in inside the company.
We decided to go with a test framework
that is a standard in the industry.
And when I joined
we had no tests.
Nowadays we have a few hundreds
and we have 107 end-to-end tests
at the moment
and although it's kind of a big number
for a short time already
they run very fast
because we parallelize them
in 10 different runners.
We give feedback to the team
in four minutes
we run these 107 tests.
We do cross browser testing.
We are trying to do things differently
and achieve great results
so we can spread the word.
And then we are starting to
with a smaller group of other teams
share what we are doing
for them to learn
from what we are doing
but also to know what they are doing
and learn from them as well
to implement good things
that they might be doing in our process.
So the advisor part is more
for when we make the project a success
then we spread the word
to the rest of the teams
that are doing other stuff.
I love it.
Again, walk on the talk.
I love your journey
your experience where you're at
the pragmatic approach to growth
you've had throughout your career.
All very cool.
So how do you
are you still doing consult
you get your classes
a little bit consulting work for Brazil
your full-time job.
What else do you do?
What do you do for fun?
What's your what are you doing?
You're not working all the time.
Not working.
I read like at the moment for example
I don't know if it was I actually
this is a book that many people
mentioned in different podcasts
that they listen to
but I think you mentioned
outlive in the previous podcast.
Yeah, I have a copy right over here.
So yeah, I bought it in Spanish.
So yours is in Spanish.
Yours is different than mine.
Yeah, I read in Spanish
in Portuguese and in English
so I can practice the three languages.
That's very cool.
So I bought it
and I just read the introduction
because when I
when you said about the book
it was like the 10th time
that I had heard about it
I decided you know what
I'm going to buy it.
I went to the store
it was the only copy that they had.
So I thought I have to have it
but nowadays I am reading
Amir Klink
There's No Time to Lose
this is a sailor from Brazil
which is a writer as well
and he
this is kind of a biography
kind of a book
but he wrote a few books
from the trips he made
the first one
he crossed the ocean
from Africa to Brazil
in a rowing boat in 100 days
the name of the book in Portuguese
would be in English
would be 100 days between
the sky and the sea
something like that.
That sounds harder than the PCT.
Yeah and then he
sleeping on the dirt
is way easier than trying to sleep
in a row boat.
It's a fascinating book
and he's a fascinating person
I even and he is
I don't know if he is from Paraty
which is a city in
in the state of Rio de Janeiro
but the way he describes
the city in his books
made me always wanted to go there
so I don't know
12 years ago I went on vacation there
and I felt like I already knew
the city because he described so much
then he wrote another book
which is called
Paraty between two poles
where he went from Rio de Janeiro
to the Arctic
and then to Africa
and then to South Pole
where he stayed 14 months
because the boat got frozen
and he built a boat
a sailing boat
for one person to sail on their own
without anyone else.
The complete trip was 22 months
it's an incredible story
and then the third book I read from him
is Sea Without End
the translation would be
where he did the shortest
but most difficult journey
around the globe
which was around the Antarctic Pole.
Oh yeah you can get around
the world quickly that way.
If you're going around the world
there's this crossing
all the longitudinal lines.
And he did it again
in a sailing boat
for one person to sail on their own
but I read a lot
I read fiction
I'm reading also the Barack Obama biography
the promised land
I love reading about technology
a bunch of books
about software design
TDD
this kind of things.
Yeah you read more than I did
when I was reading at my most
it's amazing.
Very cool.
And besides that
a few things more about me
I love exercising
so I go to the gym
like six days a week
and I love spending time
with my family
I love skateboarding as well
cooking I'm vegan
and I love cooking vegan food.
Oh a good friend of mine is vegan
and I've been pretty much
eating vegan
since I got back from the trail
because my son's vegan
and so yeah oh my gosh
you get more and more interesting.
So I've been vegan for the past four years
and before that I was vegetarian
since 2017.
I've been vegan by proximity
for the last three months
for how long since I've been back
but we made some
a friend and I made some
Indian curry from scratch
chickpea curry
it was incredible
with fresh curry leaves
went to the Indian market
got the fresh curry leaves.
There's a YouTuber
rainbow plant life
I call a rainbow lady
just a great story
while she's cooking
she doesn't take herself too seriously
which I like
but all vegan food
that I've been learning a lot from
and trying some recipes.
So that's really interesting as well
and so what you'll find
in reading
as I can segue back to Outlive
by Peter Attia
the book is about
there's a lot of science in there
he's a doctor
but it's a lot about maximizing
what he calls your health span
versus your lifespan
and all the things
you should be doing
or you can do
and the things that affect you
going down
it's all from physical health
mental health etc
that affect your ability
to have a long life
that you live fully
versus the long decline
that a lot of people
including my father had
where it just
it's just a horrible way to go.
I would like to
I would like to live my life fully
and then be dead.
Same here.
And the book
it doesn't put it quite that morbidly
but it's about like
why we should live full lives
as long as we can
and there's nothing we can do
to help with that
and I don't know if he mentions
a vegan diet directly
but I think for me
I've felt my vegan by proximity
because just don't cook meat
in the house
and I've kind of lost
most of my taste for it
is yeah, it's felt good.
Yeah, I became vegan
for healthy reasons
I wanted to become more healthy
and I feel that
I am more healthy nowadays
I exercise because
I want to have a healthy life
I also go to the gym
six days a week.
I stopped drinking
because I want to have a healthy life
Did not stop
I can't give up everything
Yeah, of course
Everyone has their things
I still do things
that are not healthy as well
but I try to live
No, good for you
especially when I got back
from the PCT
I went to the doctor
just get a physical
and got my blood test
and I have the blood
of a 20 year old
so I want to do what I can
to kind of keep
as healthy as I am
when I got back from trail
I've gained almost 10 pounds
when I got back
but I lost a lot of weight on trail
so I'm okay with that
I know why
I know how to
you know, I'm not worried
about baloney or anything
Of course
I talked to some folks
who have gained like 30 pounds
since they got back
I said not for me
No, I'm happy right here
So yeah
I love where you're coming from
I feel like we're living
you're living
a better version of my life
I kind of like it
It's good to hear all that
I hope the conversation
is inspired for someone else
listening to the other one
There's a lot in there
like I said
I'm glad that it
you were living the principle
before Brent and I
even discovered what they were
and even the first time
I went to
let's kudos
to Ministry of Testing
who had me come give a talk
on modern testing
which isn't at all about testing
and often can threaten testers
I went and did that talk in 2016
in Brighton, England
and I had people
come up to me after the talk
and thank me
for putting a label
to things they're already doing
folks like you
and said
oh this is happening
we're not making this up
I knew we weren't
but it was good
it's good to get confirmation
affirmation on those things
so yeah
today as a matter of fact
I have
speaking of jobs
I have an interview coming up
not at the top of the hour
but the top of the next hour
and then I have a meeting
good luck on that
after that
I have an interview
then I have something else
I forget what it is
anyway I have something else
and then I'm going to the gym
awesome
but what do I have
now I have to look
because I was all set
I know I had two more meetings
I have an interview
oh I'm meeting with
I'm on the alumni board
for my university
I'm having a meeting with them
after that
and then I will head to the gym
dinner with the neighbors
on a flight tomorrow
to go visit a friend
in California
etc etc
so busy life myself
I realized
that in my mini retirement
I am maximizing my time
for enjoyment of experiences
and life and cooking
and lots of gym
I play pickleball
with the senior citizens
just trying to enjoy myself
until inevitably I decide
not I decide
inevitably
I will take a job
that is more fun to do
than sleeping in
and going to play pickleball
in the morning
that's my goal
awesome
and I hope I have the courage
if I take a job
and I show up on the first day
I hope I have the courage
to walk out of this
not what I wanted
I hope you donate it
I hope I don't need it either
all right
anything else you want to add
before we close out today
this has been just a fascinating talk
I love hearing your story
our listeners are going to love it also
I'm so happy to have you on
and talk through these things
anything else you want to throw out there?
I think we covered
most of the things
that they took notes
that they wanted to cover
one other like curiosity
about myself
I love tattoos
as you can see
I have even JavaScript
running on my arm here
which means that JavaScript
can run anywhere
and I have
have I shown you?
you haven't
my PCT tattoo
oh that's awesome
there's the trail
there's a marmot up here
that's super cool
there's a deer back here somewhere
there you see him
that's awesome
I have my arm covered as well
and I'm covering my back
nowadays like the artist
that tattoos me
is in Brazil
so every time I travel to Brazil
I come back with new tattoos
I just walk down the street about a mile
but you fly to Brazil
whatever you know
yeah I have to fly to Brazil
to tattoo myself
I did a few
a couple of tattoos
here in Europe already
but most of them I do in Brazil
and it's something
that I'm passionate about as well
very cool
you are
and I have this one over here
and a couple on the shoulders
and I'm getting there
you are fascinating
and I hope that we end up
crossing paths somewhere
I hope so as well
job at a company that
that has an office in Spain
in Barcelona
so I can come visit you
that's my goal
or we'll meet in Brazil
we'll figure it out
awesome
thank you so much for being on here
this has been a delight
I have
likewise
learned so much
and I'm so excited
I just love your path
and I feel like
we definitely are
kindred spirits
at least at some point
I've found a lot of points
I just
yeah there's a lot of cool stuff about you
which is really saying
if you're like me
there's cool stuff about me
I have to think about this
my therapist
but in the meantime
just you're an inspiration for me
that's for sure
well we can be an inspiration
for each other
how about that
awesome
all right
I think this is episode 225
of the AB testing podcast
thank you so much
Valmar for being on the show
and thank you everyone for listening
we'll see you next time
thanks for having me